foreign
[Music]
welcome to the session on a deep dive on
how Google Cloud built do AI
my name is Rakesh duper I'm part of the
product management team at Google cloud
and I'm joined with two distinguished
colleagues
we'll be coming up on the stage in a
minute Cyrus he's a senior Tech writer
in the Dual AI team and Dima he's a
senior product manager in the doodai
team focused on chat experiences
so for this particular session
we're assuming that you have some basic
understanding of what do AI is so you've
been at this event for the last day or
so I'm sure you've heard something about
David AI
or Google has been talking about this
since IO so there's some familiarity
with what duetai is and what are the use
cases it covers
this is a 200 level session so we will
be diving deeper into how we built do AI
what were our experiences what we
learned and that is what we want to
share with you so as you embark on
building your applications that are llm
based or using general AI you know you
can learn from the things that we went
through and hopefully use them as you
build your applications towards the end
we'll have a brief discussion on the
roadmap
and talk about what are we thinking
about in this space for the future
so without further delay let's get
started
so first of all just a quick recap on
what dual AI is so duper AI is the
integrated AI assistance across all of
the gcp products so it's integrated AI
assistance for developers it's
integrated AI assistance for operators
for security users for data users and
everybody interacting with Google Cloud
through the variety of different
interfaces whether you're working
through an IDE whether you're working
through Cloud console or you're
interacting with gcp in other ways you
will be exposed and you will be using
duet AI
now
whether you are a beginner or an expert
everybody will benefit from Dr AI
so like I said earlier this particular
Focus will be on the specific use case
around chat experiences not the coding
not the other experiences but the chat
experiences and so we will look at what
we did around building the overall chat
experience
now anytime we're training a model for
that
we need a lot of data and for do AI we
used Google Cloud documentation Google
Cloud best practices a lot of blogs and
other content that we publish to train
the overall models
so like I mentioned a second ago
280i is exposed through many surfaces
but for this particular one we're going
to focus on the chat interface most of
the time you will see the chat interface
show up on the side panel and you can
interact with it asking questions
but as I will talk through the session
you will see in some cases it is also
embedded within the console itself
within the UI itself so it's not just a
side panel it's integrated more
thoroughly through the product
interfaces
so let's imagine a new user who's
starting to use gcp
they want to learn about gcp products
they want to they may have some common
questions about the different products
that we offer
so that user could start by asking a
question about the services gcp offers
in this particular case
what is migration Center
and do it AI will provide a response
and the response can sometimes be long
and if you are somebody who just wants a
brief response to see what is the
service really about Give me a two-line
summary you can have a follow-up
conversation and say just summarize this
in two lines and you will get an
appropriate response
now as you start becoming more familiar
with the services Google offers lots of
services you may want to go in and say
what is the most approach what is the
service that is most appropriate for
your use case
and you can ask that kind of a question
so in this particular case for example
if you want to use a data service you
can ask what is the difference between
spanner
and lidb and which one is more
appropriate for your specific use case
foreign
now as you become more familiar with
Google and all the cloud services you
want to start asking how to questions
you've decided what service you want to
use you want to be able to say how do I
do some specific task and so you can
start asking those kinds of questions as
well as shown on the slide here in this
particular case the user is asking how
do I connect my data sources to look our
studio
in response
you know do a day I will provide you a
summary of how you can actually go do
that
as well as provide some information with
links to go look for additional
information
now you're even more familiar with these
services
you want to start running some commands
against these Services now who here
remembers all the commands in gcloud all
the arguments and parameters in all the
different yaml file syntax that we have
for configuring these things probably
nobody if you do you can talk to us
Offline that would be awesome
but so you can go ahead and start asking
about questions start asking questions
about gcloud commands and in this
particular example for example here
and if a user says give me the gcloud
command on how do I list idle VMS
and so you get a
sorry I'm moving the other direction
so you get a response back from do it AI
indicating what that gcloud command is
and if you notice towards the middle of
this command there are actually two
template parameters right the project ID
and the location
as we sit here right now do it AI
provides you generic commands which
means it does not understand who you are
what projects you are in what resources
you are using
and that aspect of personalization is
something that we're actively working on
so when I come to the roadmap section I
will talk a little more about that so
when personalization is added in here
these commands will be much more
constructive in the sense that they will
fill out this information automatically
for you
now your experience with Google Cloud
becomes richer and you start looking at
other things so let's say you run into a
problem and you want to troubleshoot
something you're in Cloud logging you're
looking at logs Explorer and you see all
these different logs that are available
somebody else wrote those logs you
didn't write those logs and they are in
some Json format and json's you know a
good structured format but not the
easiest thing to understand because
everything is just like broken out in
many different parts so you can select a
specific log event
and say explain this log event to me and
so you will get an English language
narrative and a summary of what this log
event is about you can follow it up by
saying why do these kinds of Errors
happen and you will get a response
indicating why this kind of Errors
happen you can have another follow-up
question say what actions can I take to
fix those things and so you will get a
response accordingly
similarly if you're looking at code
and let's say you inherited somebody
else's code
I've yet to run into a developer who
said that person wrote awesome code and
I'm inheriting it most of the time the
first thing to say is like oh that was
really bad code
so if you do want to understand what
some piece of code is actually doing you
can take that piece of code and ask duet
AI to summarize it for you and you will
get an appropriate response as well
so hopefully this gives you just a
general quick idea about the different
kinds of interactions you can have
through the chat experience
now
this is not an exhaustive list of all
the use cases that you can have there's
many many more things you can do but in
the interest of time we decided not to
cover everything but now we want to
Pivot and show you the behind the scenes
look like how did we go about building
this what were some of the challenges
what did we learn and for that I would
like to invite Dima to the stage demo
[Applause]
thank you Rakesh hello everyone
so when it comes to applying llms
adopting them for the Enterprise use
on the spectrum of
thinking about it or maybe playing with
it experimenting and having something
running in production I was wondering if
I could ask you for a quick show of
hands those of you who are thinking
about it
Enterprise context
awesome thank you what about folks who
might be already experimenting
spotted down cool thank you running
something in production with customers
awesome thank you so much it's amazing
to say so many practitioners here in the
audience we are humbled to stand in
front of you today to share some of our
thoughts on adopting llms for the
Enterprise use and would very much
appreciate the opportunity to connect
with you all and learn outside of this
session as well
so if you considering a few things um as
far as the context so first of all we
have this very powerful new technology
at our hands which has a really wide
range of potential applications
um loms they're trained in massive data
sets can learn really complex
relationships between data and generate
text which is both informative and
fluent
however just like any technology they do
come with limitations
for one they are probabilistic in nature
which means that sometimes they can
generate incorrect or misleading output
for the users so when we're building for
the Enterprise accuracy could be one of
those aspects that we that are really
critical for our application especially
if there is even a smallest chance that
our customers might be relying on the
outputs of our application to make
business critical decisions
so it's important for us as Builders to
make sure that we put right mitigations
in place and also apply responsible AI
development principles to our day-to-day
work
in addition to the new technology we're
also looking at a new interaction
pattern which also comes with benefits
and limitations on one hand it's amazing
for both our users since it's very
simple and also is becoming relatively
recognizable across all platforms
and it's also great for us as builders
as it comes with that promise of
providing us with the universal
interface where we are no longer bound
by having to express the capabilities of
our system using traditional knobs and
dials buttons Etc
on the other hand it could be really
deceptively simple and require a lot of
heavy lifting behind the scenes to make
sure that we make it work
for example on the back end we need to
be thinking about how do we funnel those
open-ended inputs to write actions or on
the user experience side how do we
educate our users on how it works and
also how it doesn't work to make sure we
can help them use it safely and get the
most out of it
so we will talk about a few
considerations that might come in handy
as you go about adopting large language
models for Enterprise use in your own
applications
including how we approach some of those
challenges using the red AI as an
example
so before we dig in excuse me I would
like to introduce you to this software
stock simplified view of the software
stack that's powering the AI
foreign
publication which has front-end layer
which deals with user inputs and outputs
middleware layer where we are doing some
processing on the inputs as well as
responses on the way back and the back
end which houses the foundational model
and supporting our infrastructure so the
front-end layer will take care of things
like accepting user question
along with any prior relevant
conversation context
this is our prompt or a basic unit of
currency that we'll be manipulating here
has prompt goes through the stack it
gets interpreted and processed by each
layer all the way up until it gets back
to the user as a response
so middleware layer this is where we
figure out a few other things for
example intent of the user question
applies and filters add the Preamble
grounding facts as a part of the process
commonly referred to as prompt
engineering
and we will discuss details on that
later with examples
then the backend takes care of
retrieving the most relevant model in
and generating the response there are a
few other things that are happening here
for example capacity rationing pulling
citations other metadata for those of
you who might be using a managed
solution such as vertex AI a lot of that
heavy lifting will be handled out of the
box
now on the way back up
um this is our other opportunity to
double check the response for Quality
before we parse it and presented the
response to the user in a way that's
easy to understand and use and that's
that also is an opportunity for us to
highlight any known limitations of the
underlying technology
so
in a day-to-day work of working in any
product
we as Builders face many decisions
across product design implementation
details across the entire stack
as we think about those it's important
for us to calibrate those decisions
across against those responsible AI
principles
they are important for both consumer and
Enterprise application contexts
but as we unpack those in the context of
Enterprise the implications might be
different for example again safety and
accuracy could be especially important
for Enterprise applications
so we strive to apply those principles
in our day-to-day work on dot Ai and
we'll also would like to highlight and
share a couple of practical examples
with you of how we do that across the
stack
foreign
so for the rest of the presentation we
are going to assume that you already
have a product or maybe a customer
problem in mind that you would like to
try tackling with the help of large
language models
and we will talk about topics that we
think you just like us might run into as
you adopt llms for the Enterprise use
from selecting configuring and tuning
the foundational model
to experimenting with prompts and prompt
engineering
to building user experience and to all
the way up as you as you put those
layers together testing to make sure
that it all works we'll talk to you
about 14 Concepts across these four
categories highlighting techniques that
you might want to consider when you
build an end-to-end application
so from here I would like to hand it off
to Cyrus to talk about the model error
please welcome Tyler
[Applause]
thank you diva
for us as Builders a really powerful
breakthrough with language models is
that they're much easier to tailor to
your use case than say traditional
machine learning models
with language models you can take a
model off the shelf and customize it a
bit so that it works for what you're
building you don't need to think as much
about things like data labeling and
custom model training
this makes it way easier to start
to start prototyping but it puts more
pressure on selecting the right
foundational model in the first place
if you want to get started you can check
out the model Garden on vertex and if
you're not sure how to approach model
selection you can approach it how we did
we started by thinking about the purpose
of the model or the context in which
you'll use the model
for example the model Garden has
different models for our chat use cases
versus models for generating code
next you'll want to consider trade-offs
in latency
and model size a larger model might
produce better results but it will take
longer to generate responses
if you're building a chat application it
might be okay to have a bit more latency
you might be all right with waiting a
bit longer to hand results off to the
user but if you're building a code
completion service you might want to
return your you might want to return
your code suggestions as soon as
possible
foreign
after you've selected your foundational
model you can tune it or customize it
for your use case
there are three main approaches here the
easiest approach is what's called prompt
design with prompt design you're
actually not retraining the model at all
you're just providing context tokens as
a part of the prompt for example like
demon will talk about shortly you might
provide the model with a preamble that
gets prepended to every turn every
conversation turn in a chatbot
but prop design alone might not be
enough small changes to the Preamble can
have a big effect on the quality of the
responses
in these cases you can consider
fine-tuning
with fine-tuning you're actually
retraining the model with full fine
tuning you're modifying all of the
models parameters so that the responses
are more like examples that you provide
but there's a there's a challenge here
large language models are large they're
really large
this means that with full fine tuning
can often take quite a long time and it
can take a lot of compute resources
a faster alternative is what's called
parameter efficient fine-tuning here
you're only modifying a small subset of
the model's parameters
and of course prompt design and
fine-tuning aren't mutually exclusive
vertex supports both
and a great way to jump in is to use
prompt design first and see how far you
can get
then you can leverage prompt design
alongside fine-tuning to help you bridge
gaps
okay you've selected your model you've
tuned it the final step is to take the
model and configure it to produce more
creative or consistent responses
to customize responses along these lines
you can look to the temperature values
the decoding strategy the top p and the
top K values
I like to think about this level of
customization this configuration as
occurring along two dimensions
when temperature and top K are turned up
responses might be more creative but
they'll be less consistent you might get
more detailed vocab but you're less
likely to get the same response when you
enter the same prompt in multiple times
on the other hand when temperature and
top K are turned down your responses
will be more succinct they'll be less
creative but they'll be more consistent
like a lot of work with language models
finding the right configuration can
sometimes seem more like an art than a
science
on working on duet we spend quite a lot
of time getting the configuration right
you can do the same in gen AI Studio
where you can toggle these dials these
sliders and see how responses change
with different temperature values and
different decoding strategies
okay I'm going to hit it back after Dima
to talk about the middle layer and the
stack the prompt engineering layer
[Applause]
so now that you have your foundational
model selected and configured let's talk
about a few things you could do in the
middleware layer to further customize
your application to your particular
domain and use case
high quality of responses we'll talk
about both a few things you can do on
the front side on its way down as well
as on the way back up as far as response
post processing is concerned
yeah
so first let's talk about preamble
which is a set of instructions that we
pass to the model on every conversation
turn
this helps our foundational model
accommodate itself to our particular use
case so for example for that AI we would
include some instructions
to respond as an expert in Google Cloud
and this also helps us stay make sure
that our assistant stays on brand and
responds in the tone of voice specific
or unique to our organization
a few thoughts on how to use static
Preamble effectively first of all don't
think of it as a magic solution but
rather as a guideline on what you would
like your assistant to be able to do it
can be really tempting to include
everything as a part of the Preamble for
example you might want to limit your
assistance so that it doesn't respond to
questions that are unrelated to your
domain but you still need to think about
guardrails which which is something
we'll talk about in a minute
number two we also found that being
specific as specific as you can in your
Preamble hopes a lot like for example in
the case of a DOT AI if we were to get a
database related question we might want
to include more specific instructions
rather than saying be an expert in
everything Google Cloud we can say be an
expert in database Administration and go
cloud and that helps
and finally simple Preamble can go a
really long way
from our experience we recommend you
starting simple not over analyzing this
just include the most important
information you would like your model to
have
start simple iterate learn from there
and refine
if you do go down the road of optimizing
your preamble
there are a few things to consider
it all can be model and configuration
dependent but we found that even subtle
things like tone of voice punctuation
order of force in the sentence could
have impact for example at one time
during one of our early iterations on
dot AI we found that the tone of voice
for example using please feel free to
discuss certain topics worked materially
better than being more firm in saying
only discuss these topics
of course there are multiple
contributing factors including perhaps
the training data that you use to tune
your model for example in our case some
of our documentation tends to take
software tone so as a result the model
may be able to understand instruction
given in a similar language better
again this is just another state of
example to highlight the importance of
experimenting and with different
variations to find out what works best
for your particular use case
so now we talked about how we could use
preamble to provide guidelines on what
we would like for our system to be able
to do
we also want to think about what we
would like our assistant not to be able
to do and express those as guardrails
starting with the basic ones which
essentially are filters that we apply to
the user query before we send it down to
the model for response generation or
even before we do any prompt engineering
so this is our first line of defense
in protecting the user as well as
helping ensure safe and responsible use
of the large language models
we can implement this layer using
regular Expressions as well as machine
learning safety filters for that AI we
use hybrid approach where for example we
would leverage regular Expressions to
filter out Jokes which today are out of
scope of what we would like for data to
be able to do we may change this later
and then Jackson personality just to
share an example a few thoughts on
how to apply or think about basic
guardrails again in addition to
protecting the user this also helps us
as Builders to constrain the problem
space that we're looking at and make it
more tractable
those are also very easy to implement
and extend regular expressions for
example also can help us especially if
we're dealing with open-ended inputs
they can help us with break loss
scenarios where sometimes we cannot
anticipate ahead of time all kinds of
questions that we might want to blog
so it's a really great first step but
it's also very hard to do everything in
regular expressions and we might want to
think about specialized filters to make
sure we can catch more sophisticated
patterns in the user querers
so this is where the specialized or
intent based guardrails come in
so those are also filters that we apply
to the user's query based on the user's
intent
for example for the red AI we would
classify user's intent in one of many
categories for example if the user is
asking about VM cost savings we classify
that as recommendations related question
which is something that we definitely
would love for the AI to be able to help
with so we'll let it through
sometimes we get questions that are
completely unrelated to cloud like for
example recipe or restaurant
recommendations
those questions will we Block in case
without AI because this is gained out of
scope of what we would like our product
to be able to do today
and in other cases we also utilize
guardrails to flag some of the null
limitations like for example for billing
questions do that AI right now is not
able like Rakesh mentioned to access
user level data so we recommend to
triple check the response to make sure
it's valid if it's a billing related
question and provide user with
alternative means of accomplishing that
so if your thoughts on applying
specialized guardrails
number one there are multiple techniques
that exist for intent classification
with on that large language models work
really well
content classification and provide a
really easy way for you to get started
where you don't need to train the model
then again this helps us further
constrain the problem space to to make
it more specific to our application
across the entire stack the choices that
we make here can make our job easier for
example when I think about Preamble for
the red AI we don't need to be concerned
about designing it for use cases that
are outside of scope
and also finally this helps us provide a
more delightful user experience in cases
when we don't have
a good match for the for a given intent
we can fall back with a disclaimer
that's specific to to that context
and for those of you using vertex AI it
comes with generative fallbacks that
makes it make it easier to get started
and Implement something like that for
yourselves as well
so now that we have the intent and our
prompt past the guardrails we can do
some further processing on it so
grounding could be a really relevant
concept you consider in this context
the process of grounding provides large
language model with relevant facts to
improve the accuracy and quality of
responses
those facts could be retrieved from
database search engine storage bucket or
any other source we include them as a
part of the prompt along with
instructions to ask the model to
remember or keep those in mind when it
responds
for example for the AI for a question
like
how do how does bigtable handle
conflicting write requests one of the
relevant tags would include could
include details on the algorithm used
for that particular product for Content
resolution
there are multiple ways to approach
grounding or more broadly retrieval
augmented generation
you might you may also in this context
think about embeddings plugin based
retrieval this area in general is an
ongoing research and development area
with lots of discussion out there in the
community
we found that using Enterprise search
plus the large language model to
generate search query could be very
effective way of getting started
and this is here again with vertex AI
which comes with Enterprise search you
can consider implementing a similar
approach
and another observation I want to share
is that grounding is not or sometimes
it's it's not effective it could be
effective for some questions but not for
others for example in case with the AI
which is designed to help with gcp
products like Rick and shared in those
contexts grounding is very effective in
some other cases we work with AI works
with code autocomplete where grounding
could be less effective so again this is
another context where you can consider
using intent to decide whether to or and
how exactly to implement grounding for
your own application
and now we're on to the final line of
defense before we in in terms of
ensuring safe and high quality responses
on the way back we can filter out any
undesirable responses and Implement
additional quality checks
so we can leverage this step
post-processing to apply guardrails just
to double check the response against
things like whether it might be
offensive or not factual or off topic
just like we do to the prompt guardrails
should be applied here as well
it also allows us to add use case
specific disclaimers if we need to as I
mentioned dot AI for example can suggest
to double check things in certain cases
and finally this is the step where we
could Implement some additional quality
checks specific to our use case
and as needed rewrite or even regenerate
the entire response
for example for the AI we would double
check if there are any links hyperlinks
that are included with within the
response we will double check to make
sure they are valid if they're not we
would attempt to restore them and if
we're not able to restore then we would
flag this to the user transparently
of course we could regenerate uh but
that would come with additional
trade-offs so the best approach really
depends on your specific application and
your desired trade-offs between accuracy
quality and latency
so we talked about a few things we could
do
in the middleware layer
to constrain the problem space
to our domain and use case and improve
ensure high quality of responses
I'd like to also briefly discuss three
user experience design principles that
we could apply to help maximize the
potential of our llm powered
applications
number one is setting expectations which
we believe it's very important to be
clear and upfront about capabilities and
limitations of our system
considering how especially considering
how new this all is
a few illustrative examples of how we do
this indoid AI for example we would add
General disclaimers to remind our users
about limitations for example when they
open a new chat or look at code snippet
generated for them we would suggest to
double check that code
we also Implement fallbacks for
questions like out of scope for our
product
and in general failing openly as a
principle highlighting this broken
hyperlink scenario for example is
something that we use for the Nai we
think that setting those clear
expectations helps us maximize the
potential of llm power applications and
also build trust with users
yeah
second principle is around helping our
users craft good problems especially in
cases when we allow for open-ended
inputs like we do for the AI chat
we want to make sure we help our users
be as effective as they can
a couple of ways we do this on the DI
side we include a a set of curated
examples example questions for example
when user starts a new chat to help them
get the conversation started as well as
embedded in the context that explain
button that Rakesh also highlighted in
the beginning which provides an example
as well as a way for the user to dig in
examine the details and see one way of
crafting an effective problem for
themselves which can they can then apply
in other contexts as well and of course
documentation which is another simple
yet very effective vehicle for us to
help educate the user and encourage them
to experiment and figure out strategies
that work best for themselves when it
comes to
writing good problems
so we want to look for opportunities
like that to empower our users and help
maximize the potential of our llm
powered applications
finally number three
we would like to think about AI powered
applications as helpful assistance
we wanted to design them to make sure
they work alongside the user
and that's an important safety
consideration as well especially in the
Enterprise context given today's
limitations of the underlying technology
so a few examples of how do I
can how we are trying to make sure that
we help our daughter users stay in the
driver's seat
we include citations to sources that
were used to generate information so
that our users can see where it came
from and verify things for themselves
we also include links to relevant
content content relevant to a given
query
to provide a user with ability to
explore get different perspectives and
validate things
and another one is around reviewing
commands before they are run
so notice this really subtle difference
between copy a commanded was generated
versus run it
we think that subtle ux design choices
like that really matter and help us
encourage and enable safe use and also
incorporate some of those responsible
development principles as a part of this
particular layer of the stack
now back to Cyrus to talk about testing
thank you Dima
testing language models is difficult
it's really difficult
these are non-deterministic machines
with open-ended inputs but working on
duet we've developed and learned several
techniques about evaluating and testing
language models in a more systematic and
meaningful way we want to share some of
these techniques here with you today
the first lesson
that we want to share is the importance
of structured prompt data
language models are a new technology and
the new data source that comes with it
is prompt data your evaluations your
tests are only as good as your prompts
prompt data at a minimum consists of the
expected user query The Prompt and the
ground truth response what the response
ideally would look like if it was
generated exactly as you wanted
we found and we think you'll find as
well that managing prompt data in a
structured way with well-defined schemas
is absolutely critical
this way you can get all of the benefits
of rigorous data engineering from
versioning to filtering
for example
we don't want to only understand quality
broadly we want to understand quality
for specific products we want to
understand quality for specific
programming languages and we can only do
this because we use structured metadata
because we have well-defined schemas for
our prompts
you can of course do this as well in gen
AI Studio
okay now that you have your prompt data
in gen AI Studio I hope
how do you pick the right metric to make
sure that you're working towards and
building a really great user experience
on duet we found that you often need a
range of metrics not just one in order
to measure quality and the way that
matters to you
general purpose metrics like perplexity
can give you a general sense of model
quality but they can't tell you very
much about performance on specific tasks
or correctness
to understand quality from these
perspectives we built out our own custom
metrics suite and we used techniques
like expert ratings and comparisons
between a ground truth response and a
generated response with techniques like
blue scores
in order to Compare Quality across
models we leverage standardized
benchmarks like mostly basic python
problems a data set of programming
challenges designed to test the quality
of a model's generated python code
I'm going to tell a quick story here
one of the first things that we try to
measure correctness is comparing the
ground truth response to the generated
response using blue scores
blue scores are a common metric for
natural language processing tasks
they're easy to calculate and they're
often a metric that you might consider
to get started with
well we found that blue scores alone
weren't enough to measure equality to
measure correctness in the way that
mattered to us
in Google Cloud there are often more
than one where I'd answer to the same
question
blue scores weren't able to capture this
distinction for instance if the model
generated a response that showed how to
complete a task in gcloud but the ground
truth response complete the task in the
python client Library blue scores didn't
capture this the response was correct
but the blue scores were low
this was one of the first findings that
we had that led us down the path of
building out our own custom metric Suite
so that we could evaluate blue scores in
context and better understand the
outcomes that matter to us
okay
once you've chosen your metrics
how do you use them to run effective
evaluations
the key here is to run evaluations
continuously
all the time every day for every change
that you make
easy enough right
in practice you'll be making changes
throughout the three tiers of this stack
so you want to think about these
evaluations as controlled experiments
every change that you make whether it's
a change to the Preamble in the prompt
engineering layer whether it's a change
to the temperature value whether it's a
change to the tuning method they should
all be evaluated systematically
a common approach to perform these
evaluations with large language models
is to rely on humans human evaluations
we found that human evaluations weren't
up to par for us for a couple reasons
the first is that human evaluations
didn't operate at the pace that we
needed in order to run continuous
controlled experiments
the second is that we found human
evaluations weren't often that great at
measuring correctness instead human
evaluations would measure whether or not
something looked correct of course what
matters to us is whether or not the
answer actually is correct
so an effective approach that we
developed was a automated testing
framework
with automated testing framework we
could calculate quality metrics
programmatically then we would calibrate
those metrics against expert ratings
this approach is very effective but
remember
we're building a product that is going
to have a great user experience for real
people for humans
in the end Direct customer feedback and
human evaluations should always lead the
way
all right I'm going to bring Dima and
Rakesh back up to the stage
all right so we have talked about quite
a few quite a few 14 accounted topics to
for you to consider when you go about
prototyping your own llm powered
applications just to reiterate three
meta points that cut across number one
Enterprise applications there they tend
to be unique and Target to specialize
Target specialized use cases
on the one hand this can help us as
Builders to make the problem more
tractable by applying constraints across
the stack but they also come with unique
requirements that we need to keep in
mind
for example we talked about accuracy
there's many more
number two large language models of
surrounding development as a domain so
as Builders we need to stay agile and
flexible keep up with new trends and at
the same time balance fast
experimentation with those with doing
development responsibly
the good news is that the getting
started is easier than ever vertex AI
provides a library of foundational
models and all the tools that you need
to get started
potential applications of llms go Way
Beyond chat that we highlighted today
and we hope that the general principles
we discussed will come in handy as you
build your own applications
super excited to see what you do next
so oops
so um hopefully this gave you a good
overview of what are the things involved
in developing llm-based applications
and we put a lot of effort into AI but
what are we thinking about as we move
forward so you heard about some of the
challenges uh with duete with any kind
of llm based application it's new
technology it's probabilistic to gain
the trust of your user you know they
expect perfect responses but with the
probabilistic model it's hard to give a
perfect response right the things that
we're going to focus on in the near
future is make Enterprise Readiness for
Do-it AI a much more holistic experience
which means reduce hallucinations we
want to improve the quality of the
responses we want to improve the
accuracy of the responses and one thing
that is probably the most critical is
understand the intent of the user right
I mean the user can ask any kind of a
question right we're not constraining
them what do they actually mean and how
do we provide the best response to the
intent of the question even if they have
spelling mistakes or poor grammar but
how do we provide a good response to
that is the first thing second thing
like I mentioned at the beginning is
focusing on personalization you know how
do we make it understand your project
your resources you know other billing
data that Dima was talking about so that
the responses that we provide are much
more rich contextually and the last
thing is the steward AI experience will
not just be a side chat experience but
we much more integrated like the logging
example I gave you so whatever you are
in the cloud console or in the IDE and
if you're looking for a specific piece
of data and you want advice or
suggestions or help about that you'll be
able to invoke do it AI right from there
so
um for those of you who may not have
attended other duet AI sessions or if
you're interested in more here's just a
quick list an introduction to duet AI I
think that session already happened
yesterday but its recording will be
available so as you go back to your
companies you want to share that you
know that's one of them there's a
developer Focus developer productivity
Focus session that's tomorrow morning
there's a spotlight session this
afternoon at 4 45 which kind of brings a
lot of these things together and if you
want to learn about prompt engineering
there is a session tomorrow as well
above all if you want to kick the tires
and try this on yourself and see what
the experience looks like go to the
innovators Hive and you know there are
demos there which are showing you the
live product you know try it out there
well thank you all very much for coming
we really appreciate your uh you know
being here and listening to us and enjoy
the rest of the event but if you get an
opportunity do give us some feedback
through the application thank you very
much